(hip hop music)
(partygoers talking loudly)
- (Purple-Hair Girl) Sorry,
sorry. 'Scuse me, I'm sorry.
'Scuse me... Sorry...
(hip hop music)
- [Partygoer] Chug! Chug!
Chug chug chug chug
chug chug chug chug! Oh!
(guitar strumming)
- Oh wow, cool shirt.
- Oh, thank you!
- Hi, I'm Bridget--
- Ooh!
Oh! God, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
- It doesn't matter. It's totally fine.
- Yeah, I can get you a new one.
- No, I honestly didn't even want this.
It's just straight vodka, so
you were doing me a favor.
- Okay, I guess you're right then!
- Yeah!
(both laugh)
- Cool, it was good to meet you.
- [Black Haired Girl] So
yeah, brunch in the morning,
eleven o'clock is good?
- [Girl With Lei] Yeah,
no that'd be great.
You wanna go to the Den?
- Yeah.
- They have good hash browns.
- Dude, they have great hash browns.
But I really gotta pee,
- Me too!
- so if we could go out of here.
- Today.
- Get outta here, man.
Jesus.
(collecting groaning)
- Wow, really guys?
- Dude, there are bedrooms, man!
- That's so disgusting, God.
- Woah! Hey, what are you doing?
- What? We always go in together.
It saves time.
- I gotta change a tampon,
and like you know that
scene from the Shining
with the elevator and, and the blood and,
just like, you wouldn't
wanna go in there with me,
it's gonna be nasty.
- But you don't get your
period for another 13 days.
- It came early.
- Oh my god, we're waiting here.
- Okay, so I'm gonna go in alone.
And you just, like,
stay out here. Alright?
- Alright, well, yeah.
- Bye.
- Have fun in there.
Do your thing, whatever.
(sighs)
- This anybody's whisky?
Whose is this?
Alright.
(hip hop music)
- Aw, man. Check out
the chicks here tonight.
- Yeah, man. It's too bad you've
already fucked all of 'em.
- Nah. Not all of 'em.
- Jesus.
- [Purple Haired Girl] (Laughing)
Crazy line, am I right?
You know in England,
they call lines "queues".
- Wait, are you the transfer student?
I heard about you!
- Oh! All good things, I hope!
- No, I heard you murdered someone.
- What? No!
(crowd murmuring)
- Aw, dammit. Someone took my whisky.
- This anyone's pizza? Is this free?
- [Lei Girl] Lemme guess.
You are pretending to text people
when you're really just refreshing
your Instagram about 10,000 times.
- (Laughs) Is it that transparent?
- I've been there. (laughs)
- I feel like I'm the only
sober person at this party.
- You're definitely the only
- Oh my God.
- I'm June, by the way.
- You're in my work study program, right?
At the library?
- Yeah, yeah. Me, and
every single English major.
- Guilty.
- I mean, schools need teachers, right?
- There you are! (laughs)
What are you doing? What are you drinking?
Who's that?
- Hi!
- This is, um...
- Madison.
- Madison here, and
she's telling me about,
she's an English major,
and I think that's so cool.
- Hey, hey, remember that time you said
that English majors
were pointless? (laughs)
- I never said that.
I think that the spoken
word, and word in general
are just very beautiful, beautiful things.
'Kay, excuse us.
(laughs drunkenly)
Dude.
- What about her?
- Nah, she's too, I dunno,
she's too...
- What, smart?
- Eh, something like that.
- What about her?
- Oh yeah. She is...
Hot.
- Well, see you tomorrow.
- Hey!
- Aren't you in my biochem class?
- Am I?
- Let's dance.
- Okay, you can keep doing that.
I'm actually gonna go
talk to... Madison...
- Oh, I can go with you to talk to her.
- Tiffany, college is a time
for you to explore yourself.
You know?
- Yeah.
- Just really, develop friendships that,
you know, would last a lifetime.
- (sighs) You mean so much to me.
- Maybe we should take this
opportunity to, you know,
branch out a little bit.
- Wait, what are you saying?
- I wanna see other people.
- Oh!
- Outside of our dorm.
I wanna make other
friends, is what I mean.
- Yeah. Sure, whatever.
- Okay, you're mad.
- No, no, no. It's fine. I...
I have to go mingle.
I gotta go.
- You know, you're the nicest
person I've met all night.
- Yeah? Guys in England aren't nice?
- I mean, they're okay, too.
- What do you say we get out of here?
- I don't know...
- Aw, come on.
- Drinking?
- A little.
( chuckles)
- Sorry, you said "drinking"?
- Oh, yeah. Yeah.
- A little bit?
Here, you want some...
I'll get you another drink.
- Okay.
- You don't want mine.
Um...
'Kay.
- Aw, come on.
You're gonna leave already?
- Hey.
Come on.
- What?
- Let's play some pong or something.
- Yeah, I'm busy.
- Leave her alone, dude.
- What the fuck.
She's fine.
- I'm just gonna go.
- No, come on.
- Hey, let her go, man.
What are you doing?
Hey. Hey. What are you doing?
Come on, man. You're drunk.
- This party sucks, doesn't it?
- Yeah. It does.
Someone stole my whisky,
there's no more pizza left,
and I was hit by approximately
14 beer pong balls.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- That's a lot.
- And now my ex-boyfriend is here.
Flirting with the girl I always knew
he had a crush on, so...
- Female intuition is never wrong.
- I know, right?
(sighs)
- I feel like I should
just go talk to him.
- No.
- For a minute.
- Yeah, you're right.
He can do whatever he wants.
I'm gonna leave before
I do something I regret.
- Oh... 'kay see ya.
- Um... I mean, you could
come with me, if you want.
You know, we could get high and watch
Bojack or something.
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely,
yeah, let's please do that
- I mean, we don't have to watch Bojack,
we could watch whatever we want.
Do you like that show?
- Hey. Sorry about that.
- S'okay.
You know, he seemed so nice at first.
- He...
is not...
nice.
Probably don't wanna hang
out with him anyway, really.
- Then how come you hang out with him?
- I...
don't know.
Maybe I shouldn't. (sighs)
- You know, I think
I'm just gonna go home.
- Can I walk you out?
- You're not gonna... you know...
- No. Do what he did?
No. No...
At this point, just wanna
get away from him, actually.
- Okay.
- Cool.
♫ People grow and people change
♫ Things'll never be the same
♫ Tell me why you even came
♫ People grow and people change
- Is this your iPhone?
Anyone's iPhone? No?
I'm just gonna
use the calculator real quick.
♫ Already know it's gotta change.
(swooshing, creaking hinges)